ردا على سؤالك عن قضيه هل كانت الجزيره
العربيه منزله او كان شعب ومجتمع الجزيره
العربيه مجتمعات هذه الذي يكون
فسيفساء جميله جدا سواء بتضاريسه او
بعاداته وتقاليده مختلفه او بقبائله التي
قطنت في هذه الجزيره من شمالها الى جنوبها
من شرقها الى غربها مرورا بوسطها الحقيقه
الانعزال هو نوعين فيه انعزال ضار وفي
نعزال ايجابي ولا يجب علينا ان عندما نقول
ان بعض المدن والمناطق في الجزيره العربي
كانت شبه منزله لا يعني هذا انعزال كان
سيئا بل كان جيدا ومتميزا انتج حضاره
متميزه وهناك مناطق وممالك عربيه كانت من
فتحه وليس الانفتاح الذي اساء الى المجتمع
ولكنه انفتاحا ادى الى بناء دول ومجتمعات
حضاريه متميزه ادت دورها على جدار الحضاري
ما اساميها انا دائما بالجزائر
الحضاري بس
سبيل المثال حائل حائل من ال- من
المجتمعات التي اعتقد شخصيه من خلال دراسه
العدد من نقوشها خصوصا ثم دين وكان مجتمعا
منزلا ولكنه لم يكن منعزلا انعزالا ضارا
بل انعزالا ادى الى الابداع
كما نراه من كم الكبير جدا من الرسوم
الصخريه المتقنه التي تدل دلاله القاطعه
على انه الانسان في تلك الفتره وصل الى
مستوى حضاريا في الفنون لا يمكن الحقيقه
همم التغاضي عنه او القول بانه غير متميز
بل انه المناطق في على سبيل المثال في
دوامه الجندل هنالك رسومات موجوده
بالابعاد الثلاثيه فلا يمكن ان يصل
الانسان في هذه المنطقه
ويستخدم هذا الرسم وهذا الاسلوب اللي بعد
الثلاثي ما لم يكن مسبقا لديه على فكره
هذه من اقدم الرسومات ذات الا بعد 30 في
العالم جميله جدا اقدم منها حتى اليوم همم
في في الجوف منطقه الجوف
فالانعزال ليس لما نقول انه هذا المجتمع
منزل ليس بالضروره ان يكون انعزانا سيئا
بل هو نعرف ان عزال السيء لكن لم يكن
منطبقا على الجزيره العربيه اذا اخذنا في
جنوب الجزيره العربيه نجد ايضا الممالك
كانت منزله قد اساتي نسى على سبيل المثال
مثل قتبان مثل حضرموت في بعض الاحيان لكن
عندهم ايضا ممالك كانت منفتحه ومجتمعا كان
مفتحا كما هو عند كما هو في شمال الجزيره
العربيه مثل همم على سبيل المثال في الجزء
العربي ديدان او تيماء يعني المجتمع
التيماء والمجتمع الديداني كان مجتمعه
مجتمعين منفتحين على العالم نجد همم لا
نجد في الجزيره العربيه
كم وتنوع النقوش الموجوده في تيمه وفي وفي
ديدان في العلا اليوم اللي تم اليوم العلا
في بقيه مناطق الجزيره العربيه كلها معين
في جنوب الجزيره العربي كانت ايضا كان
مجتمعا مفاتحا لذلك تجد اييي جاليات
منتشره في الجزيره العربيه سواء في الفاو
في جنوب في وسط في جنوب منطقه الرياض او
موجود في منطقه العلا او خارج شبه جزيره
العربيه ايضا لذلك هنالك الحقيقه نوعين من
الحضارات حصلت في الجزيره العربيه منها
المفتاح مثل الديدان التي تعتبر الحقيقه
من اقدم الممالك العربيه في الجزيره
العربيه مساويه في ظني الى
نفس الفتره الزمنيه لسبا في جنوب الجزيره
العربيه لانهما ذكر في نص رامي وجد في
العلا مملكه ديدان الديدانيين ملك
الديدانيين
وسبائيين فهذا يدل دلاله قاطعه على
الحقيقه على التواء العمق الزمني اولا ثم
ما نج حقيقه من تعدد في الاديان وتعدد في
المذاهب وتعدد في الافكار وتعدد في
الاعراق عاشوا في ديدان هذه يدل على انه
مجتمع منفتح الحكومه الديدانيه او الماء
العائله المالكه الديدان والمجتمع
الديداني لم يمانع ابدا في اي جاليا تاتي
الى الى ديدان لم يومان عن تمارس طقوسها
وان تستخدم كتاباتها احرفها لغتها فاستخدم
المعين لغته واستخدم ثمود لغته واستخدم
همم صفاء ايضا كتاباته هي قليله صفيه
الحقيقه لكن الحرامي استخدمه ايضا كتاباته
الاغريقي واليوناني لما جاء ايضا نستخدمته
جنبا الى جنب معا لغه ال- الديدانيه عكس
بعض ما هو موجود اليوم كالاعتقاد بانه كل
شيء خطر على المجتمع عندما يكون اجنبي او
يكون غير غير محلي ما هو صحيح ان احنا نجد
الحقيقه همم عكس هذا في الحضاره القديمه
الانفتاح على الاخر ضروري تفهم حضاره
الاخر ايضا ضروريه ثقافه ايضا ضروريه ليس
بالضروره ان نتبناها وليس بالضروره ان ان
ايضا ان ان نحاربها ولكننا ناخذ منها ما
يفيدنا ونترك ما لا يفيدنا